un peu avant 9h ce matin 10 heures à
l'heure romaine
le président de la république est reçu
au vatican selon le cérémonial
solennelle réservé aux chefs d'états
catholique sur la place saint-pierre
d'abord où un liseré blanc sur le sol
délimite la frontière entre l'italie et
la cité papale et dans la vaste cour
saint damase ensuite centre des palais
pontificaux les gendarmes coiffé du
bonnet à poil
les gardes palatin au chac qu à plumer
et les gardes suisses dont l'uniforme
fut dessiné par michel-ange rendent les
honneurs au général de gaulle qui a été
accueilli par le conseil général de la
cité du vatican
le prince carlo pacelli neveu de pie xii
c'est la troisième fois que le général
de gaulle se rend au vatican en 1944 il
y rencontre et pie xii et il ya huit ans
jean xxiii qui remettait au président de
la république le collier qu'il porte
aujourd'hui en même temps que le grand
cordon de la légion d'honneur ordre
suprême du christ la plus haute
distinction pontificale un détail peu
connu le président de la république
considéré comme le successeur des rois
de france et chanoine honoraire de la
basilique de saint jean de latran
applaudi par des français de rome auquel
il s'adressera tout à l'heure le
président de la république
s'entretiendra ensuite en tête à tête
avec paul 6 pendant près d'une
demi-heure dans la bibliothèque du
souverain pontife dont l'intimité est
soigneusement protégé par la gare de
nobles madame de gaulle et les
personnalités présentes parmi lesquelles
messieurs pompidou et couve de murville
et l'ambassadeur de france près le
saint-siège monsieur brouillé vont
ensuite entendre l'allocution du
souverain pontife est la réponse du
président il à fond j'aime ça nous donne
la personne des plus illustres de ses
fils vi or le père comme déjà difficile
il a fondu à sa patrie c'est assez beau
dire mais c'est le président ont
l'honneur et le plaisir que nous restons
trop de contre visite
puis paul s'ils souhaitent qu'une
entente fraternelle s'établissent entre
tous les états la réunion des six
européens hier à rome est à ses yeux le
symbole d'un rapprochement qui devrait
inspirer d'autres nations mais ce n'est
là qu'une étape
sous la voûte de la paix et de la
véritable fraternité entre tous les
peuples du globe
il faut viser plus loin élargir
l'horizon aux dimensions du monde et
c'est ce qu'a voulu rappeler notre
récente encyclique sur le développement
ce nouveau ou de la paix aux nôtres
quant aux problèmes posés aux hommes
dans l'ordre temporel en ce moment de
l'histoire du monde la seule liste itude
que leur témoigne votre santé ne laisse
pas non plus d'occuper les esprits et
les coeurs ainsi relais qui la vente ou
de la paix qui s'en doute n'a jamais été
plus aveuglément menacé pour tous vos
messages pour tous vos appels depuis
celui de new york en présence de
l'assemblée des nations unies jusqu'à
celui que vous lanciez il y a peu de
jours lors de votre pèlerinage à fatima
grâce très saint père vous soit rendue
c'est une bien belle journée pour tous
disaient enfin le pape au moment où le
général de gaulle prenait congé de lui
avant de se recueillir quelques instants
dans la basilique saint-pierre et de
consacrer quelques minutes à la visite
de la chapelle sixtine